so we have these nine balls right over
here and we're going to assume that they
are completely identical at least
they're identical in appearance but one
of the nine balls is heavier just a
little bit heavier is heavier than the
other eight balls and my question to you
is what's the minimum number of times
that we can use this scale in order to
know definitively which is the heavier
ball so there's some number of weighings
using the scale that after that number
of wings i know for a fact that i found
the heavier ball we're not going to do
something based on luck that you just
happen to pick the right ball when you
weigh it
it has to be 100 chance after this
number of weighings that you have the
ball and so what is the minimum number
of those what is the minimum number of
weighings of using this scale and i
encourage you to pause the video and
think about it as long as necessary to
come come up with your own conclusions
so i'm assuming you've given a go at it
so i'll give you a couple of hints now
so my first hint is that you can do it
in exactly two wings of the scale if i
do two weighings of the scale i know for
a fact that i can find
not just through luck i can find
definitively the heavier ball so that's
my first hint and if that helps you i'll
pause the video i'm about to give you
another hint
so my second hint is that with each
weighing of the scale
you should be able to rule out
two-thirds of the balls that are
essentially still candidates for the
heavier ball so if that helps you once
again pause the video
so now i'm assuming you've had a go at
it and maybe you were able to figure it
out maybe you weren't so now let's work
through it together
so i mentioned that in each weighing you
can rule out two thirds of the ball so
how do we do that so in the first
weighing what we're going to essentially
do is take our nine balls and and put it
into
into three groups of three and we take
two of those groups of three so
we take this group let me actually do
that in a different color
so we can take
this group of three right over here put
those three balls on that side of the
scale and then we could take these three
balls and put it on that side of the
scale
and so you're essentially weighing three
versus
three balls
now
there's a couple of outcomes here you're
either going to have a balance
you're going to have the left is heavier
so let me write that say it's going to
tip down so the left
the left is heavier
or the right is heavier or
the right
is heavier
now what does each of these tell you
well if this if they balance that tells
you that the third group has the heavy
ball
so actually let me write it this way if
this is group one group two
group three then this tells you that
group three
has heavy ball
has
heavy
ball
if the left is heavier then we know
group one has heavy ball has a heavy
ball group one
has
the heavy
ball
and then finally of course if the right
is heavier we know that group two
group two has
the heavy ball
now just like that with one wing we have
narrowed it down to one of the three
groups we've essentially narrowed it
down we now know that our heavy ball is
one of three balls it's either one of
these three one of these three or one of
these three and so i just repeat the
process but instead of doing it with
with with three balls at a time and i do
it with one ball at a time so if i'm
taking three balls
if i have three balls
what i could do
is
i will now so my step two i guess i
could say
my step two i now
weigh one versus one
and once again i have the outcomes so if
they are balanced
if they are balanced
then that means the so once again if
we're taking say this group of three
we're in the balanced situation from the
first weighing
and so if we put
if we put this ball
here
and this ball here if they are balanced
then we know that this must be the heavy
ball because these two are the same
if
if the left
goes down if the left goes down then we
know this is the heavy ball and likewise
if the right goes down
we know that this is going to be the
heavy ball
so this is actually a little bit of a
brain teaser that you see it's a pretty
common one it's actually even sometimes
you'll hear it in some job interviews
but you can see it comes through out of
the idea that through each weighing you
can rule out two-thirds of the balls and
so you could use this principle if you
want to derive other brain teasers what
if you had 27 balls how many wings would
you need what if you had 81
and sometimes when you see this brain
teaser instead of giving you a nice
clean i guess you could say power of
three right over here they might give
you something off so they might give you
eight balls but the exact same principle
holds if you had eight balls you could
you could split it up into two groups of
three and then two more and then do the
same and then do the exact same process
but i think people like to do the eight
balls because it takes you a little way
from the idea of maybe you have to
divide it into groups of three or
something like that anyway hopefully you
have enjoyed this